why's women
need motivation watch the top ten would
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's more inside you as well
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so get ready to be great at
getting attention beat the Sun up and
learn from everyone with Grant Cardone
and my take on his top ten moves a
success vol 20 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be great at getting attention when
you're in front of a customer do I have
your attention when you're eating
attention you need to know something
else is trying to get their attention to
you're in competition with everything
and you don't need to make attention you
need to get attention they're tied
together
attention is money get it keep it
multiplied that means when I'm in a
meeting I need to get your attention I
need to get it I need to be sure I have
it I need to keep it and then I need to
multiply that attention because if you
don't keep my full attention you ain't
gonna get none of my money
rule number two beat the Sun up grant
rant of the day the one you need to live
with wake up to every day is that right
there okay
beat the Sun up folks you got to beat
the Sun up if you can't beat up the roll
up of the Sun up you're gonna get beat
up in life okay I've been doing this for
a long time now say beat that thing up
that monster out there that warms this
planet that nourishes and gives us light
you can't live it to next life if you're
not beating the Sun up so many of you
complain about how much time you have
you don't have time man because you
don't beat the Sun up get started early
and when you get started early that
means you need to shut it down early
okay shut it down or at least so you get
sleep I was I was I was asleep last
night at nine o'clock so I could beat
the Sun up the market this morning and
see
the world wake up with me rule number
three learn from everyone I don't I
don't need to spend time with a bit too
I need to study a handful of people that
have proven over time they they were in
part and that they did something Walt
Disney he's a mentor of mine
what guy almost went bankrupt free time
that is the spiritual adventure like
like how do you do that how do you ever
drink Howard Schultz with Starbucks I
don't like his political viewpoints but
I do like the baguette know everybody
told him Starbucks is a bad idea
he's like yeah okay whatever it's a
terrible idea Steve Jobs total maniac
like neurotic and I wouldn't do any of
that stuff but I do it I do like the
guy's ferocious commitment so if I can
take Rob those pieces from different
people right
and say hey man I want to be more like
that guy or that gal right
you know so so you know what I'm saying
like like that that's my that's my deal
like how can I mix it up with your and
how can i I'm interested in leaving
something that lasts longer than I do
rule number four grow from victories I
know a lot of people say they they learn
from their losses but III don't I look I
get better because of my successes I
don't need a lot of quick tonight
longest I'm not interested knows yeah
just takes a longer to grow again yeah
get back to where you wanna be you know
Mike Mike tell me something the other
day in the hotbox he says you know cuz
he started thinking differently about
some of the stuff I was saying to him
mmm and he said I said you know Mike I
know you blame you know you think your
success is what hurt you but I guarantee
if you look back those first fights you
were winning everything about everything
brightened up in your life when you
started winning in life hey you know my
grades got better mmm he's got more
confidence dude of course he even
learned better and I said you know III
know I don't learn from the losses I
learned from successes and then I try to
repeat those things do more of those
things that are and then get me to get
the get the get the get the the bucket
gets bigger yeah right the rim gets
bigger the field-goal gets bigger right
everything gets bigger it's easier to
make the shot because I have the wins
and I think it may it is I feel so bad
for people particularly around money
that they never have the victories mmm
back to back enough victories to be like
wow what else could I do also if you
want to learn to have more self love
check out my 250 for series it's free
the link to join is in the description
below
my dreams are first every day then my
wife then my kids I could take care of
my wife and my kids now would you agree
I abandoned this this is the fuel for
Who I am I've been at a point in my life
where I thought I thought less than me
than anyone thought of me how many you
been there you have to go build
self-confidence rule number five get
addicted to success when I walk out of
treatment center the counselor skill I
think you've been
in the treatment centers you know you
you basically share all your secrets I
was telling like I want to be rich I
want to be famous I want to write books
and the guy's like dude if you don't
give up all that [ __ ] you will be back
here in 30 days he's like you need to be
satisfied I never forget the speech on
the 28th day health insurance had run
out so they're gonna kick my ass hep
right because the money ran out he says
if you don't give up on all these ideas
these these grand grand illusions and
the grandiosity you don't give up on all
that yummy that I hated and I threw all
that addiction and a [ __ ] obsession
with destruction the you you like
understand as well as anyone and they've
talked about so eloquently I threw all
that obsessive energy into work to
become a master at a few things and and
that's what's really changed my life in
my direction to where I can just run
down a Pathan and over the period of 35
years create something for myself that
you know I'm sitting in a room with my
man you obsess rule number six study
wealth 25 years ago I had three friends
my life has not always been this
I had three friends one was a drug
dealer
one was my girlfriend who didn't love me
she loved the drug dealer more than she
loved me she loved the drugs she's still
in drugs today
and my third friend couldn't be a friend
of himself much less to me I had three
favorite friends in my entire life I was
the black sheep of my family five kids
everybody in my household was worried
about grant everybody must two sisters
my brother my mother were convinced I
would end up in prison or I would end up
dead
I should not be here today so a 25-hour
recommitted to my education but this
time I started studying not things that
were in books but people that had
actually created wealth not people that
had made money but people that he
created wealth this is completely
different I was no longer studying
accounting and economics I was studying
wealthy people and only wealthy people
I'm not talking about the doctor
there was a neighbor that makes a
million dollars a year and he's working
18 hours a day and he hates his job
right he's working seven days a week you
can't ever spend time I spent about the
yacht people I'm talking about the
people that are spending as much time as
they want on vacation I'm talking about
the car dealer that had 28 car
dealerships or 82 car dealerships that
has in disposable money and I quickly
realized something
that the wealthy people had financial
freedom and no one else did okay a very
small percentage of people lots of
people have money
my uncle had millions of dollars he was
terrified about his money wouldn't spend
it acting like a miser buried money in
the backyard I realized my parents had
it wrong the information I had that was
wrong I started comparing the wealthy
people to what my dad did my dad worked
every day every day of the week if he
wasn't working at the office he was
working in the yard they saved money
they cut their own grass okay we ate all
our food we turned the lights off we
didn't waste anything and that was
uncertainty it was insecurity and it was
fear and it perpetuated uncertainty
insecurity and fear and and all the
lessons about money money doesn't grow
on trees a penny saved is a penny earned
eat all your food people are starving
okay money money you don't waste it
don't play with it all that creates
insecurity and it's incorrect rule
number seven be persistent once I decide
I'm gonna do something it's like there's
no lettin the the chances me letting go
is something that's important to me a
friend like I am either the best or
worst friend a person asked why so
because because it like if if you and I
are in a claw
and something goes down I will be there
swinging it out okay I have no chance to
win in the fight I can only be a
distraction to the thing throw the
bottle but you're not gonna see me just
run Yeah right so so and I'm not gonna
run from my dreams like I'm not gonna
run from my kids I'm not gonna run from
Elena I'm not gonna there's nothing to
Lena could do that caused me to like run
away from her rule number eight expand
your network I'd get comfort and nurture
from them when I failed that's not what
you need you need to expand your network
when I was getting comfort from the
people that love me and accepted me as I
was
I should have been expanding my network
by investing in the conference's summits
the masterminds to get access to what
other people think the way other people
operate and to their success so I could
learn from them and possibly as
importantly with the network you get to
collaborate with other people remember
nine hire the right people we look for
compliance and willingness before
intelligence mmm so you don't look for
skill you look for someone who's I don't
look from the culture I never look from
potential what do you look for then just
like yes I'm willing to we hired the way
the Patriots do okay you know they don't
hire the best guys right they never did
they get all the Rings oh they do okay
there's three people in charge on that
team there's not 33 it is a dictator
there's a dictator on that team you
study all sports I mean it's pretty much
like that too
you know I mean Portland Portland
doesn't really had that you know they
Lea leaves Korea alone and he leaves you
know Duran Duran alone and they're doing
good you know got me it's a different
style right but but um but somebody's
closer with superstars yeah man it's got
to be so hard
yeah everyone's got a personality I'm
yeah yeah yeah so let's see how long
that leg is seeking laughs now what have
made three years now yeah you know their
area and see if they turn themselves
apart but I know that New England
Patriots thing works consistently
there's an owner he's not involved he
brought in touch this guy bill runs the
deal yeah
and then and then bill gives the ball to
brady it says a good deal yeah you know
so they hire they they they hire from
the lower half of the draft
they don't overpay for anybody and if
you don't comply you're looking off the
team they're gonna win without a great
person I like that
I'm you'll number 10 the last one before
a very special bonus clip is hustle dude
I'm in the desert right now I'm doing
the deals OK by me and literally look
what's the difference 141 million for
140 million dollars on 142 out here the
desert how hot is it out here well it's
a cool winter day it's a pinch it's 106
degrees out here dude look look at you
jacking me around about what million
dollars let's do the deal
the daily to say yesterday now I have a
special bonus tip from Grant on how to
have a dream that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
which of your goals do you need to
hustle harder on number two what's the
next right hire that you need for your
business number three what will you do
this week to expand your network and if
you promise to take action after
watching this video we don't just watch
videos now we do something about it
give me a hashtag believe in the
comments make that promise to yourself
and then get to work when I was 16 years
old I couldn't help my mom all I wanted
to do was help my mom the only reason I
wanted money was I didn't want my mom to
be scared and I couldn't solve the
problem I told my mom when I was 16
years old one day I'm gonna become super
successful and when I do I am not gonna
worry about money and I'm gonna help a
bunch of my goal our goal my family's
goal my team's goal is to literally
cover this planet invest energy and
resources in the entire planet shaman
will make friends all over the world
I want people all over the world
my name because if people don't know you
they can't flow
if you want more grant cardone and check
out the top 50 ident on him the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there don't watch the news
decide when you leave here today to make
the news did you don't get attention
today you have absolutely zero chance of
being successful